i know that we've mentioned tyler's
pseudonym plenty and i don't think
everyone here knows who tyler is or what
the story is around tyler so do you mind
quickly just outlining that so that
people can
re-watch and say okay now that makes
sense i didn't give the context to sure
sure okay so i wrote this book i called
it american cosmic in reference to
um the russian cosmists because to me
russian cosmis is a great book for any
of her listeners um
um
by i think it's henry young
and
it's about the belief systems of the
people who started their the russian
space program and so when i started
american cosmic and i met tyler he had a
very similar belief system and tyler was
this person who actually reached out to
me
and he was part of a
secret program now they're not they're
known not to be secret and he had
clearances and that sort of thing and he
worked for every almost every space
shuttle launch okay he's a mission
controller and um he's a very
fascinating person
i kind of kept him at a distance for
about a year and a half before i
actually met him in person
and then he took me and gary nolan to
new mexico to an alleged crash site for
ufos because he told me that ufos from
the 1940s he told me that i didn't
believe in ufos and he said you only
believe in them as kind of like
imaginary things he said what if i
showed you evidence that
and so this was where i was like
automatically suspicious i was like wow
you know this is crazy but i'll go
um because you know it's still evidence
there's still data even if he's
disinformation it's still data so um
anyway so that's who tyler is tyler's
fascinating space program person